[Music]
okay gus
vl 750 let's play e4 and i want to see
how our initial set of okay never mind
we're facing an alkyne the move of
course is e5 and
i know you all know that so you play e5
knight t5 you play d4
and in this critical position after d6
there are
three or four viable setups that you can
play
you can play knight f3
which for a while was considered the
topical move
the old main line is c4
and then chasing the knight away and
then taking on d6
and then in my opinion the line that you
want to play if you want to be a
mainline player who tries to punish
people for bad openings if you want to
be someone who
people fear
you play the fantasy against the karo
khan
you play
you know smith moore against sicilian
and you play the four pawns attack
against the alakan it's not that hard to
learn there isn't that much theory
and in return you get
essentially the chance to blow black off
the port so i think i've already played
it a couple of times in the speedrun all
right so knight c6 this is the theor the
main line
and if you know nothing about the four
pawns attack you would be tempted to
play knight f3 here knight f3 is a bad
move
knight f3 walks right into black's hands
because it allows the move bishop g4
which puts pressure on the knight which
in turn puts a lot of pressure on the d4
pawn
so you don't want to play knight f3 you
also don't want to play knight e2
because that blocks the bishop and
blunder c4 the way that you want to
defend the pawn
without allowing a pin
is the move bishop e3 which is no you
don't want to go d5 here because d5
blunders the e5 pawn and after bishop f5
you essentially want to delay the move
knight f3 for as long as possible you
want to develop your other pieces first
so first we develop the other knight
and essentially notice that black's
bishop has already moved which makes it
safe for us to now play knight f3 now
believe it or not bishop g4 is a move
here
uh it's so annoying that black even
sometimes plays it down a tempo but now
that we've developed our other pieces
and now that we have d4 under better
control bishop g4 is no longer that
dangerous okay so now we complete our
development with bishop b2
both sides castle we're following right
now the main line and
uh black plays f6 you might remember
this from my game against robson in the
us chamber of my round one game where i
had this from the black side
now white is better here and
essentially the reason that white is
better is connected to the fact that we
have better better central control black
has a a backward pawn on e6 and we have
very nicely positioned pieces i mean
look at how everything is in the center
everything is very compact and we want
to make a couple of surface level
improvements to our position this is
still theory so it's not like i'm
inventing this the first improvement
that we want to make is to connect our
rooks
and uh yeah connect our rooks and
prepare to put them essentially on c1
and d1 so we want to throw in the move
queen d2
and it looks like this is where our
opponent's theoretical knowledge ends
this is one of those positions
a lot of people struggle in because
there's no super concrete plan you just
have to make
a bunch of improving moves okay so he
plays bishop g4 which to be honest i'm
not familiar with i think i understand
what the point is the point is is he
wants to take on f3 and then take on d4
so we need to respond accordingly by
protecting the d4 pawn
and the move that makes the most sense
is rook 81 notice that if black takes on
f3 anyway we would want to take back
with the rook a very common blunder in
the alakine
is people who automatically take back
with the bishop and blunder the c4 pawn
but notice that the knight is exerting
pressure on that pawn we have to keep
the bishop on e2 for the time being
until we play b3 that is
okay queen e7 now the other drawback of
the move bishop g4 that that he just
played is that it relinquishes the e4
square and why is that important that is
quite important because we can play the
move knight e4 at some point we can even
play it now in fact i think we will play
it now
and why is 94 a good move well 94 is a
good move because it pressures the
bishop on f6
and i think that we do want to trade
bishops trade the bishop because if we
trade the bishop
then d4 is no longer under pressure
and we can then essentially get our
hands free from the necessity to defend
our central puns that makes sense so we
want to play knight e4
and then we want to take on f6 at our
convenience
i would not move the rook from the f
file
miniature case because if we move the
rook from the f file then we open the
doors for bishop takes f3 and we would
have to take back with the pawn which is
highly undesirable
in order to keep c4 protected
is a32 possible a3 is completely
unnecessary i'm not sure what a3
accomplishes bishop takes f3
okay so now we have a choice we have to
decide whether we take on f6 first
because that's a check or do we play
rook takes f3 well let's calculate if we
take an f6 first
the issue with that is that black would
will take back with the rook and do you
see what the problem is the problem
there is that after rook takes f3 rook
takes f3 again we have to take back with
the pawn and ruin our kingside pawn
structure again we can't take back with
the bishop because c4 is going to be
hanging so we should take first on f3
the f6 bishop is not going anywhere
because bishop h4 can always be met with
g3 and in general bishop h4 is not a
scary move that bishop is just really
really really bad
why is the c i mean
why is any pawn important right the c4
pawn is the center pawn we don't just
want to give it away for free
h6
all right so
let's not rush
with knight takes f6 check that bishop
as we have already established isn't
really going anywhere
so it's worthwhile to put a little bit
more pressure on that bishop before we
capture it what move comes to mind a
very typical move right this is all very
natural
what move comes to mind
yeah the move rook d to f1 the rook on
d1 has essentially done its job as a
protector of d4 now we can leave those
duties to the bishop and the queen
and after rook to yet our opponent
completely misses the danger here
now we are ready to take on f6 this is
really the last moment in which we can
do it otherwise we lose d4
but the point of rook df1 is that black
can no longer
keep his kingside pawn structure intact
we can definitely we definitely want to
trade rooks here
and we force this extremely weakening
move g takes f6
now it's not the end of the game because
bishop takes h6
allows black to take on d4 and in
general we have to be very very careful
in order to not lose this d4 pawn
so let's try to find a good move in this
position
okay well
how should we think about
this position in general well it's it's
quite clear that our general strategy
uh should be to attack the king the king
is wide open we should try to attack it
what tools are available at our disposal
as a way to develop an attack against
the black king well there's a very kind
of typical attacking motif that comes to
my mind
which is a rook lift right you notice
that after g takes f6 the g file is open
so it makes a lot of sense i think to
get a rook to g3 and that would greatly
increase the strength of a move like
bishop takes h6 the queen should be kept
on d2 for the time being i don't want to
give up d4 until we are ready to do so
until we're essentially ready to deliver
checkmate because the best way to give
black a lot of counter play is to allow
knight takes d4 and open up the d file
knight e5 paper tiger that doesn't do
anything at all
how should we respond to that move
should we take the knight
well no we shouldn't take the knight
because our queen is pinned
now
you would start by looking for ways to
move the queen away with check
but there is no such way
and once you realize there is no such
way you also have to notice that the
rook is hanging so best thing to do is
just to move it to g3 with check
now how has knight c6 to e5
changed the position well the knight is
no longer exerting pressure on d4 which
means that d4 has now two defenders and
only one attacker which means that the
bishop or the queen
at least one of these pieces is free to
roam about the cabin
what does that mean that means that we
are ready to take on h6 and we're
threatening a totally devastating check
on g7 or threatening queen before the
game is essentially over
so we've fully dismantled the setup
it's not 100 over if black defends well
but knight f7 further exacerbates the
situation by
clearing the g7 square for our bishop
now it's basically over
okay king h7
so we have one last line of defense that
we need to break down
and the line of defense we need to break
down first of all notice that queen h6
is impossible because there's a knight
on f7
so one approach would be to
try to eliminate that knight and play
bishop h5
but that's a little bit slow
the other move that comes to mind is
bishop d3 check bishop d3 check looks
almost like checkmate but black can
block the check with f5
but in that position i think
to the rescue comes a very typical
attacking motif right you want to crash
through if you can somehow take twice on
f5 you're going to force the king back
to g8 and the king is going to be forced
to walk right into a devastating
discovery so we have one more piece
that's not involved in the attack yet
and that's the queen we want to involve
the queen where should we go with it
well there are multiple ways we can play
we can play queen e2 which is a great
move going to h5
we can also play queen f4 to set up a
sacrifice on f5 and also aim at the h4
square in case black's queen let's say
shifts to d7
so i think both queen e2 and queen f4
are essentially winning on the spot
um let me think for a second which one i
would prefer
yeah let's play queen f4 that was my
original plan
very straightforward attacking play
notice that we're not doing anything
insane or not sacrificing all of our
pieces we're just identifying
uh a way forward and then sending it up
we're also bringing all of the pieces
into the attack knight d6
now as is very common when you're
attacking
every one of your opponents move you
have to ask yourself which squares are
now opened up for your pieces because
one door closes another door opens and
if you do that then you very quickly
identify the best moves that's a good
technique in positions where your
opponent's king is wide open and there
are there are a lot of infiltration
squares
so knight moves away from f7 what
squares are opened up well the h6 square
is opened up
so we give a check
and then we step back with a bishop and
we win a queen and we win the game
pretty
simple chess right
so you can see how how effective the
four pawns attack is
at this level in general if you know
openings at this level you you get a
huge advantage
so f4 defe
uh we followed the main line for a while
we followed the main line for a while f6
cf bishop f6
and um
okay so queen d2
now in this position if memory serves me
right black's best move is queen d8 to
e7
like in order for black to keep an
acceptable position
they've got to know
uh very
you know reams of theory just because
the position is so like positionally
dubious
so no the allogan is actually not that
bad if you know it very well
it's definitely dubious
it's definitely objectively worse for
multiple reasons but
if you know it very very well and my
good friend brian tillis who's a
national master he's done a trustable
course on the alkyne so at like a 16
1700 uh level it's
it's a pretty decent chess opening if
you know all of the ins and outs of the
main lines
but the problem as i've already
explained many times is that people tend
to play these openings without really
knowing them they're just kind of
experimenting and they get away with it
at their level
but they never really get acceptable
positions because they're just kind of
winging it all the time
and then they think the opening itself
is terrible
so queen e7 is the main line
and here uh this was my game against rey
uh the most popular move in this
position this is a great example of when
the most popular move is actually not
the best
which sometimes happens right the most
popular move in the position isn't
always a good move sometimes people
uh just reach a position
and none of them have
studied the position conscientiously
with an engine for example and so they
tend to make the same mistake over and
over again
and the mistake that people tend to make
in this position over and over again
is let me just verify that i'm telling
the truth
and ray did not make this mistake uh so
rook 81
rook 88 sorry it's not this position
okay 81 or kd8 it's this position
so clearly
there is an x-ray against the queen
and the main move
uh logically enough is queen d2 to c1
moving the queen stepping back away from
the x-ray
d4 is well protected by three different
pieces and it's attacked by three pieces
so it cannot be captured but it turns
out the queen c1 is a mistake that
allows black to equalize and it's so
much more popular than the second move
yeah and ray's move which is extremely
rare but the best move in the position
is king g1 to h1
there's a very specific purpose to this
move which totally disarms black's main
idea
why is quincy one wrong
reason it's wrong is because black has
e5
now e5
itself looks like a completely innocuous
move on account of d5
and this pushes the knight back and
white just has an amazing center and an
amazing position
but there's a very very nice idea here
black can play the move knight d4
sacrificing a pawn
okay well white says thank you very much
knight takes d4 he takes d4 bishop takes
d4 and it seems like black has
absolutely absolutely no follow-up you
might say oh what about takes takes and
queen c5 trying to pin the rook
well that's not very effective because
white can just play queen e3 i think or
even queen d2
and there is no way to put more pressure
on the rook
so the compensation here is insufficient
you might say oh there's a four queen e3
check that's about as gambit
so there is nothing in this position but
here you don't have to take on d4 and
you can play this very crafty move
bishop g5
bishop g5 in this position
all of a sudden the queen is in some
trouble the queen is no good squares it
has to move all the way down to a1
it has to move all the way down a1
and after queen a1
black strikes again out of the clear
blue sky with the move c7 c5 hitting the
bishop
and the idea is that if white takes on
poisson there is a
very easy tactic rook takes d4 and then
bishop bishop e3 check picking up the
rook and winning a piece
so again bl white is pushed back even
further with bishop f2
and now comes the main idea of this
entire operation without this next move
white preserves the extra pawn and
consolidates and everything is great
who can try to find black's best move in
this position the only move that keeps
the initiative going it's really the
only move that creates a threat
yeah it's bishop c2 bishop c2 attacking
the rook
but the interesting bit is that after
rook to e1
uh a lot of you i'm positive are
thinking oh it's bishop d2 trapping the
rook on e1
but in fact that is not the move
that is not the move
um because if you play bishop d2 then
white has bishop g4
bishop takes c1 rook takes c1 and white
counter-sacrifices in exchange but gets
a huge initiative in return for it this
position is bad for black
[Music]
for example like queen d6 you give a
check on e6 and then you go bishop g3
and
black's pieces are shoved all the way
back and black is in huge trouble queen
c1 queen e3 is coming
this is no good for black
but the move here is actually rook takes
f2
and there are still
uh
two there are actually two
correspondence games
that followed this line one of them from
2003 rook takes f2 rick takes f2
and bishop e3 and black gets a huge
initiative in return for the for the
sacrificed pawn and the computer's
evaluation here is equal
so this
entire line is the reason
why the most popular move which is queen
c1
is actually a mistake and that's not a
very well known detail if you're an
alkyne player
this is something that you should
definitely memorize and definitely know
very very well
and so for that reason you want to play
king h1 well how does king h1 help
well the reason it helps is if black
goes down the same line and goes knight
d4 takes takes takes bishop g5
first of all the queen
used to be on c1 which would mean it had
to go to a1 now it can go back to e1 and
stays relevant
and black has none of the ideas
connected with rook takes f2 connected
with bishop e3 check bishop e3 is no
longer a check the king is so much safer
on h1 than it is on g1 so you can play
bishop c2 here but that's not going to
do anything where k1 and white is
totally fine white is up a full pawn
um
so after king h1 in my game against
robson
i ended up playing
just sort of a neutral move i played
i mean i knew that he would probably
play king h1 i knew that was the best
move
uh
but i didn't last very long because
black is just worse here i played h6 he
played h3
and only after
rook d7 did ray go back to c1
and the inclusion of king h1
makes e5
totally ineffective and without this
idea black's position just kind of sucks
and i quickly
ran out of helpful moves to make and
ended up losing
in very one-sided fashion you can find
an analysis of that game on my youtube
channel so
yeah this was a classical game this was
round one of the us championship in in
october
so this was not that long ago
all right
so bishop g4 to my knowledge is already
an inaccuracy because it allows
this knight to get to e4
and pressure the bishop
after rook ad1 queen e794 black is
already in quite a bit of trouble i
think
black is already in quite a bit of
trouble because we're exerting pressure
on the bishop
remember that black's position is
already bad to begin with just because
of this backward pawn on e6 and the
awkward knights so this only adds insult
to injury after bishop f3 or f3
and i think that the last chance for
black
uh was after h6 rook df1
to just kind of bite the bullet and go
back to d7 you have to defend this
bishop you cannot allow white to take
and take back with the pawn because the
king is just too too weak there
after 97
black is still holding on the position
sucks
for many many reasons white has many
ways to improve the position
but
okay at least black is black is still in
the game
maybe a3
and before expanding on the queen side
is a good idea we would have to think
here maybe we would want to take the
bishop anyway and just get two bishops
for two nights
but in any case this would have allowed
black to stay in the game
yeah rook 88 knight f6 the game is over
takes takes takes
and now very important mover cuff three
how do i find a move like this well you
just evaluate
how the position has changed as a result
of the change in pawn structure
and you should notice that the king is
now wide open
and you should quantify that what does
it mean for the king to be wide open
well
when when you say those words what you
really mean is that the g file is now
open so there is a direct line of fire a
direct avenue that allows you to reach
the king
and
from there it's very easy once you
understand that the g file is the way to
go
then you spot the rook lift rook f3
95 rook g3 check
no i think quantify is what i meant in
that case g3 check and then bishop takes
h6 quantify as in
operationalize make something more
concrete it's not enough just to say oh
the king is open i need to attack it
in what way is the king wide open
and then once the attack rages on when
play bishop takes h6
we find bishop g7 check
and then we find bishop d3 and queen f4
aiming to sacrifice on f5 and drive the
king back to g8
what if he runs with the king toward the
center
yeah there were many many good moves and
i say this every single time when we
have a crushing position like this if
you're asking a question about an
alternative or you're wondering why i
didn't play something else
chances are that your move is also good
there usually isn't just one winning
line in these types of positions
there was a question about the king
running toward the center well the king
will not get very far if the king goes
to f8 we take on h6
and now there are multiple multiple ways
to win but what i like to do in such
positions when the queen and the king
are
in close proximity like this you need to
start looking for skewers so the
simplest move is just rook g8 check
if the king moves to d7 you have a
skewer but you can also just take the
knight with check because the the pin is
no longer there the king is has stepped
in front of the rook
and if the king goes back toward f7 then
you go rook g7 to win the queen this is
part of the
idea that i've shared many times which
is that when you're attacking you have
to look at ways to win material
sometimes the conclusion of the attack
isn't always checkmate it can just be
using the weakness of the opponent's
king to win a ton of material
and that's basically all she wrote a
simple game but i think a pretty nice
one bishop d3 queen f4 and then once the
knight moves away we notice that h6 is
now free for the taking and we sink our
queen there
pretty straightforward stuff
[Music]